[Music]
you know some [__] yeah yeah yo you
can't be doing this a man is to get off
[Music]
[__] nipple I love you I said I love
you [__] oh my god what if you say what
one more time I'm gonna cut your [__]
eyes out okay first of all shut your
[__] mouth when you're talking about
number two you know you're kind of
blindsiding me with this whole love [__]
right excuse you blindsiding you David
we have been dating for two weeks that's
okay we need to have a conversation
we'll wait okay how long have you known
me two weeks right two weeks tops
and in that short amount of time how are
you so sure that you love me David I
just know that I do
le that's not an answer honey I need to
know that my heart beats to know that it
beats
Palli that is the dumbest [__] thing
I've ever heard
I'm trying to be romantic here you dick
I understand but why do you sound like a
ancient Chinese proverb [__] you okay
you know what if the tree fall in the
for me I'm just trying to get to
understand you a little bit okay so
let's just break this down for a second
love is a feeling and an emotion right
and overtime feelings and emotions
change so how are you so sure
okay whoa they love you happy
mm let's go that's not it
you just need to trust
honey I would but remember in the past
couple weeks you cheated on me already a
couple times so that whole trust thing
is like right out the window you know
I'm saying okay there's huh
yes it does that's the whole point
because this is a conversation that
we're having right now
[Music]
I gotta go so you just go have the chill
honestly I
and the words really live something that
you can't know I remember the first time
I told you I farted in front of you
right back at you baby tomorrow comes
my heart's beating I know
[Music]